hi guys my name is markiplier and
welcome back to ultimate custom night
happy 21 million subscribers my channel
is old enough to drink 21 million
[ __ ] times how you guys doing I'm
still sick but I've been playing this on
my own like a like a [ __ ] so yeah
pretty good you're good Thank You Dez
Beal I am NOT the best in fact I think
if anything I appealed the lowest common
denominator which is why so many people
have subscribed to my channel but thank
you so much 20 million I didn't have
anything planned not a goddamn thing
it's been a little busy the past few
days in the past few weeks but uh I've
been I've been practicing this on my own
and I've come up with a strategy that
should should be what I need to finish
this I'm gonna show it to you first
I'm gonna show you guys and then I'm
gonna explain it because I i've been
playing 55 mode and I've technically
beaten it I got to four thirty but I've
forgot to go over to foxy funtime foxy
and this is hard I would say just this
55 mode is the hardest of any of any
five nights at Freddy's game this is
harder than this here is harder than all
the other twenty modes I would say maybe
right up there with five nights at
Freddy's 2 just this just five mode so
I'm just gonna show you cuz I can't even
I can't even begin to talk while I'm
doing this so I'm just gonna go for it
and I apologize if I'm rusty I've been
playing all morning and obviously I'm
sick so I was losing steam but let's
just let's just I'll shut it and then
I'll explain I know people are still
getting in here and I know it's
a little early but frankly I was like
I'm so tired I just want to be done so
I'm just gonna do and you guys watch
I'll explain afterwards
I was free that's expected that is just
about as expected I that's the one thing
that always throws me cuz I've got like
the technical process down pretty well I
mean it's really just like how fast can
you go that's that's what the test is
here and then how much can you remember
at the same time let me try that again
and then I'll explain because I didn't
get far enough to be able to explain
what I'm doing it alright I'm sick I'm
still sick I don't know what I caught
some kind of cold just makes me feel
like Garbo but thankfully I still am
able to do this
to a house they're early
oh my brain is a Spartan ow my ass no
that's not what I wanted
ah
foxy of course I knew I was forgetting
something I forgot the foxy usually
usually foxy foxy I'm using the DEF
point on foxy that's pretty much the
go-to I was dead anyway there
all right I guess that was enough to
explain what I'm doing so I wanted to
share these tactics with everybody I
think and if ever there was a way to
beat 50:20 mode I think this is it and
let me just let me walk you guys through
what I'm doing because it's I know it's
too fast to really get any get any sense
out of so what I'm doing is the first
step is turn off fan open monitor and
hit power generator at the same time go
to duck to place it here because if
there's only one path some will get
stuck there as long as you regularly
turn on the heater
you'll get there then block the first
one just in case it usually doesn't even
go here but I put it there just in case
here look at monitor scan around for
coins and then every time you pop down
you want to turn on the AC as soon as
you can I mean there's other things to
take care of but you want to around the
AC especially when you're out you don't
want to compound your power now the most
important thing is every time you bring
up your monitor oh close the side vent I
found that the animatronics in the side
vent only come through when you put your
monitor down or put your monitor
and if you do it every time you put your
monitor up then they're never going to
be a problem so it contains it really
well and it helps you get faz going
anyway so you keep an eye out for here
hello goodbye DD actually I I don't even
mind DD anymore cuz uh DD doesn't
actually buff any of the characters
before so it's just a matter of like you
know just keep an eye on everything so
really why I chose this strategy
especially with the way it is oh yeah no
wait there's there's multiple things
when you flip up the monitor you close
that but before you do anything every
time you open the monitor you hit this
button and this button this will clear
the screen of foxy and Balloon Boy if
they pop up because Balloon Boy he only
requires a monitor change while foxy
requires a a system change so I found
that if you just hit the same one it
still clears them so then you went I do
it here because that way I can look at
toy Freddy and I can see how the corner
of my eye if something's changed or not
and that's gotten so like subconscious
lately that I just do it automatically
but that together that combined gets rid
of four annoying characters and makes it
so that you're never surprised with
something on screen that shouldn't be
there you know what I mean and then
every time I pop the monitor down put on
this just in case because most of the
time the vision is just gone you can't
see anything so you might as well just
for safety reasons put that there so
it's kind of just works like that
it saves a ton of power because then
you're not compounding this you don't
have this always down you can only do it
you know when you need it
that's me slamming that down and open
and then no character ever appears out
there the only thing that's tough to
remember is remembering when that is up
or down because when Afton comes out the
side vent he only hello spring-trap he
only comes once you gotta make sure that
you know which is up and which is down
so that you can get that the other thing
is you know listening with all these
slamming the slamming of the door sounds
a lot like chicas pots and pans so it
can be difficult to
discern which is where and so that's
just yeah that's that's pretty much it
the rest is just trying to hunt for
enough fast coins to get the death coin
to get rid of foxy because foxy I find
if you're moving quickly it's really
hard to maintain looking at foxy funtime
foxy it's fine if you just remember the
numbers and pay attention but everything
else just needs you know I just don't in
20 but I don't think there would be
enough time for foxy to get away from
foxy so that's the strategy makes sense
everybody alright by the way hey how's
it going thanks everybody for being here
I'm gonna I'm gonna now that I'm warmed
up I think I'm sick by the way happy 21
million thing y'all still fit for being
here thank you for all the sponsors and
the the super chats here's your birthday
money thank you savvy savage all of your
gamer hi mark I hope you feel better
Jessica backer a money drop knee hi mark
you're doing great in these games I hope
you're doing well and I hope you can
come to Virginia on your next tour Eric
Peterson blazing a ninja gaming hey Mark
you should play Detroit become human I
was gonna stream it and then everything
happened last week eat the rude new
sponsor Jacqueline Carville hey Mark
love your channel king of Ooo now well I
don't know right now but uh let's let's
do this I'm pretty sure you can only
sponsor on YouTube gaming right now but
I'm in talks with YouTube right now to
fix that because it should be a channel
wide for me right now but those dudes
okay so I'm not gonna talk because I
don't want to talk
also watching for her but that's pretty
that's pretty obvious I've actually
gotten pretty good at that on those side
sounds you can slam the doors without
even coming out of the monitor I got you
slam too fast I have noticed there are a
few things that if I do it too quickly
it's just gonna end up badly for me 215
215 see that's what I was talking about
you got to remember when it's up or down
cuz I'll always died of that a lot
actually just because I always forget
which ones where if it's up or down
because I'm not looking at it I'm never
really looking at it so I just got to
keep it in my head which ones which
[Music]
whose voice is the creepiest one died
well I mean fun time foxy cuz this is
usually the one I'd die to more than any
other
yeah the vast vast majority of my deaths
are fun time foxy easily see I forget
ah got him I'm so backwards on there so
you can clear clear and out of the way
get what I've don't even need to worry
about it
Showtime oh [ __ ] what am i doing I
totally forgot what I was doing I always
check the other one first just because
you never never never ever ever ever
want to be it's it's just like you got
to balance the hard game overs with the
lengthy soft game overs and so just
making that the making the effort to you
know it's kind of straddle it out you I
need to get the death coil and get rid
of you the one person I'd died to more
than every every everybody else is fun
time foxy and that's just because I
don't pay attention it's it's uh the
hardest piece of information to get for
me is the time because it's top right
corner and it um yeah it's just like my
eyes just naturally don't go up there so
I've been I've been trying to get there
yeah yeah I'm sick um of super sick I'm
getting better today but yesterday man I
was I was just like walking death
sometimes those guys don't go away for a
bit
and it makes it difficult I'm pretty
sure those three I like to I try to
double-check as much as I can and all
the while you got to be listening for
the clashing of the pots and pans
because technically you could hear them
from the from the office but with
everything else going on it's nearly
impossible occasionally you'll get these
guys coming through and I imagine that
in for when when this dude starts
slamming his bangers together just put
on the silent ventilation that's it
three o'clock [ __ ] is it up or down hey
I got it
let's never get that down okay I've got
a problem because I'm currently oh [ __ ]
do I have enough for the death point do
I know it the last [ __ ] I'm done I
always I always get jumbled when the
she's going on but yeah but it shouldn't
be much longer sorry about the pitiful
attempts I was making a pretty much
three minutes Plus every time before I
started streaming and it's probably
because I'm talking I keep saying oh god
they're gonna talk of us do to
concentrate
here I go flapping my big old gums
ah that's another thing that I do a lot
I accidentally hit the accidentally hit
the change music button when I'm going
to wind the to wind the music box and
it's just like this is 55 this is not 50
20 but this strategy I believe is
applicable to 15 20 I'm not gonna do it
now because I don't want to throw me and
myself off but it should be I should be
able to beat this from relatively I know
I said I was closed yesterday I actually
I actually I really was but I was I was
doing a sloppy like luck based I wanted
something that was a lot more repeatable
and something that could be applied to
20 mode so I had to come up with new
strategies that kind of exploit the way
these characters kind of work you know
and a lot of that comes from just like I
know I played these games before the way
their program they can only work a
certain way so even with 50 of them like
there is there's some method to the
madness it just doesn't seem like it on
a surface to am also did I mention
yesterday that the guitar can only be in
a few few places
Oh foxy goddamnit
I completely forget about Fox now I got
it
pay attention to everything come on
Marky move those my coins
where's my coins oops that's dangling oh
[ __ ] oh yeah 2:00 a.m. okay
which I forgot again it's the same thing
god I dyed it as simplest things over
and over again this is cuz I forget one
minor detail that was again like I said
earlier just I forget which way the vent
is it's if that's the problem with this
strategies you have to remember
everything that you've done but I think
if you if you got good enough of that it
and like I have I've been getting pretty
good at it then eventually it'll pay off
because it's super adaptable to a lot
harder difficulties I think anyway but
that's just me
I can't see I'll just come back at 1:00
anyway no on a risk he's in a hurry I
was in a hurry I was in a hurry I should
I should have just actually no I think
that's one of the situations where its
death is almost unavoidable because if
you have one of the toy bonnie's or
withered Bonnie waiting for you
that require the the mask and it's a
timer and it gets wrong with this it can
coincide to screw you but it is what it
is
yeah cuz because what I'm trying to do
is to remove as much RNG as possible you
can't eliminate it entirely but can
diminish it
I'm clicking behind the head just in
case to try to get up get up
Minister healthy areas I look to the
side to see him if she's there I do it
all the time but that's I'm not looking
to the vent because I know the vent
unless I don't know where the vent is
and then I don't know the three that was
intentional I just wanted to get the
death join in the way
come on oh boy
it's really giving it to me it's giving
me the business right now you want to
save as much power as possible in the
beginning phases just because you're
gonna need to use silent ventilation and
if you're doing so like right here right
now if you're doing silent ventilation
while looking around it's going to be
incredibly detrimental three am also
bowl or ax is o P I believe I'll talk
about in balance just because she
obscures your entire screen and I think
that's a little unfair because I mean
it's a sound based thing but you know
whatever
I'm just complaining the complaint at
this point oh [ __ ] oh I flubbed my mask
I flubbed my mask I flubbed my mask yeah
I know I know I gotta stop talking but
it's okay I can get this I'm not using
any power-ups either because I wanted to
practice without crutches because I
believe it's it's solely beatable
without crutches I haven't used the
powerup in any of my practices but I do
believe power-ups are mandatory for 5020
mode if it were possible which I still
don't know if it is but uh yeah
not the worst thing in the world bonanza
excuse you those are actually good
opportunities to just cool the room down
because you can just sit there with the
a/c while they literally are stupid all
for never get before anymore please tell
me I remembered I did I remembered I
didn't know if it was one I ever not oh
hello I'm low on power they've really
thrown it at me in the beginning and I
was flubbing up some of the stuff oh
[ __ ] ah foxy
god damn it ice for some reason I've
been forgetting foxy this especially
this time you can't death coin him after
he's already been unleashed like so I
don't know I'm just gonna keep going but
is basically game over at this point but
just cuz I want the practice yeah soon
as the head gets on the table it's
pretty much gonzo
yeah I guess I might as well just death
coin no I'm done yeah he's there he's
there well I would have died anyway
because I would have forgotten about
chica yeah this is the reason I can do
this so fast
is it because this is what I was talking
about about my method of learning is
first off you have to find the most
efficient way and no matter what it's
like no matter how hard it is you just
have to realize with repetition you'll
get faster at it and you'll get faster
at it until it's not really a big deal
anymore so I find the most efficient
method even if it requires some crazy
Mouse agility and then I just practice
that until it's still stuff also I've
been playing these types of games for
years now so I've gotten weirdly good at
them but I'm probably not like the best
I could be nor and I'm not going to be
like I don't even know if I have time to
try to do 20 mode because I've been
practicing this for like days now and
it's it's a bit of a it's a bit of a
challenge now I'll make a few attempts
at it but like I said I've never I've
never had a need 20 mode never been
mandatory
oh no not now was it a 1 a.m. I might
all thank you it was not a 1 a.m. that
is just one of those rare opportunities
that exist to bone you
death coin you all right so now we don't
have to worry about that anymore still
here the pots and pans
the thing is I'm probably going faster
than I need to go to be honest oh I
forgot something
it's hard to tell which one will get
there first and I never really am 100%
certain [ __ ]
I've mana I do that a lot where I I
completely forget what I'm doing and
then I get Flum bold and here's 3:00
a.m. oh hey I'm kind of low on power
right now I would say I would be a lot
more comfortable with a lot more power
than what I have oh [ __ ]
also you can just go ahead and if you
have the money
go ahead and buy the other uh-huh
sorry my brain just ticked that it was
there was no there was no did it did it
go away again did holy [ __ ] I've never
seen that do that twice in a row like
that yeah I'm I'm a little low on power
oh oh oh [ __ ] okay 5 a.m. I had time
yeah I'm pretty low I saw spring-trap
they're just out of the corner of my eye
yeah
the only I'm gonna let my [ __ ] I
don't know if yes see this is where I
would want more power just for the just
for the I forgot about the heater yeah I
forgot about the heater there that's
alright
that was close but I flubbed my power
management that's the other problem
because I'm turning off the on and off
the the a/c like crazy but sometimes it
can be very it can be very easy to
forget it like any anytime you see me go
like duh-duh-duh
that's me forgetting have everything
yeah no I don't I don't think I would
have won that anyway because most likely
in that scenario fun time foxy would
have a requirement to be there at 6 p.m.
and that would be game over if you can't
if you have no power for it
let's try it again closer though that's
that's more what I'm what I was getting
at away I went out of the Forest Service
sorry even even I man even I just [ __ ]
up royally sometimes in fact I [ __ ] up
royalties a lot that was just a plain
old goof that was a complete Oh wrong oh
but no no excuse for thou and those is
me being awful
[Music]
I think it moved yeah it did
yeah that's like a really hard thing to
see and super annoying but it's totally
possible that's probably like some
contrast settings you can have your
monitor app that's not what I wanted all
over the place boink and we got you oh
[ __ ] we don't have enough come on one
more
I need more coins I need way way way
more coins than I have right now thank
you that's exactly what I was hoping for
wait okay
wasn't sure if there was still pots and
pans
okay 4:00 a.m. that was just pure luck
that that didn't get me because I had
completely forgotten oh [ __ ] I might
have I might have just killed myself yep
I I killed myself
unless I can get ten five coins yep here
we go this is the end this is the end
for me god I forgot I for some reason my
brain thought Bonnie my plug my brain
thought Bonnie for the plushie no foxy
was already gone right there yeah my
brain thought Bonnie for some reason let
me give this another good old college
try a good old 21 the moooo try a sweet
savory average try thank you all so much
for subscribing for the most average
podunk youtuber around
oh how many times did I open up the
monitor and just stare at Rockstar Boni
like hey how are you doing there fella
you enjoy the make yourself at home
I don't know why you could be here
there's no possible reason that you'd be
here oh well I'll carry on doing me you
do you look so stupid that's stupid
yeah we got a new channel name it's the
average the the pretty pretty knots
quite goods so that's what we're called
subscribe to become a pleasantly average
today everyone wants to be a part of the
most mundane and boring YouTube channel
on YouTube so mundane and boring I have
to say you did twice in that context oh
that's really stupid of me I am just I
am cocking it up harder than I've ever
cocked anything up in my life
it's not 3 a.m. I didn't even need to be
there oh well bonus points for being
proactive every hour oh wow Jesus I
don't like the bow Laura she's not fair
oh god I'm loving them flubbing them
flubbing I'm slobbing there we go oh I'm
alive somehow down come on every time
every time I don't remember a why every
time I'm so stupid I'm so stupid I can't
remember when it's up or down I'm so
stupid
up down I have a 50% chance every time
and I lose it every time boy I'll get
there guys I'll get there everybody hold
on to your butts it's about to get wild
I'm so stupid
I'm so stupid I'm so stupid goddamn my
brain is just not working oh yeah oh I
can't see I think he's there yeah more
coins more coins more coins no coins
actually no coins for me you're welcome
1 a.m. show [ __ ] we're gonna be
tight here Wow
see that's what you gotta do that's
that's one of those situations
[Music]
all right
Oh who would you throw in all right boy
we got oh that's easy enough
oh plushie God why am i collecting coins
if I don't buy see it's like this is the
thing every time I die it's not because
some like horrible circumstance of
chance it's because I'm the [ __ ] it
that's the only time I die the only time
I ever die in this game is when I'm just
a goddamn idiot now Dee Dee's fine I
don't care about Dee Dee anymore dee dee
dee dee I can totally handle dee dee dee
dee dee da dee dee and I are pals at
this point
3 a.m. to 15 I'm Way loans on coins I
should have 10 on I should I usually get
like 15 by now it's been really light on
coins one minute exactly I was doing so
much better at practice I was doing so
much better cause there is so much
better
if I wasn't such a cock-up but I'd
probably be good I'd have a good
reputation you know well what was that I
don't know what I just did there you are
pretty baby see afternoon
why can't you always attack right then
and there
oh come on go away go away go away no no
not now
gimme ah I hate you I hate you all I
literally hate all of you you all are
sucking ass y'all are ass suck the ass
of the suck yeesh
so hard to tell with all the slamming
going on oh no I got guys bye-bye
bye-bye yaaaa
Oh see we got a straggler there I also
sometimes double click that but you know
that's an entirely different problem
[Music]
why oh my god if that that kicks me in
the ass later I'm gonna be so mad I
don't know why I do that
who's gonna go I hate this situation
who's gonna get there first oh good
thank goodness oh my goodness
wait Oh sir four is not that god I'm
such an idiot
that's how I run out of power that's how
you run out of power Oh for a even said
it I said it I said it I said it I said
it and I said it I said it and I said it
and then I said it again and I still
forget I'm such an idiot I say this is
this is what's wrong but this is what's
wrong with me
all right listen this is what's wrong
with me I'm dumb there you go
you know the mystery has been solved I
know I know
mark seems depressed and is insulting
himself more anyone noticed that oh [ __ ]
it's sick give me a break
God every time I kiss it's the same
people that were like commenting on the
Smosh video like he obviously hates much
like of course I don't
this guy's I'm not the center of
attention doesn't mean I'm depressed
you think I walk around the street with
a good old hello everybody
no absolutely not
come on man I'm not you gotta be out of
your gourd I look depressed I'm sick one
more guys sick hahahaha hey there we go
right here this is gonna be the one
uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh
three I missed out on some coins there
that's okay uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh
uh-huh
my face hurts uh-huh how unfortunate is
it wow that's so great
ah-ha ah-ha ah-ha ah-ha ah-ha ah-ha
ah-ha ah-ha
oh oh [ __ ] I didn't okay thank you it
was nice to me I totally missed that
okay 3 a.m. let me actually get because
this is a good attempt so let me just
actually get serious for a second there
Wow oh I totally forgot about that okay
come on ah you kidding me
damn it I missed it I missed it by that
much and that's it that's so finicky
about the toy Freddy for some reason
like sometimes toy Freddy just like
feels like he accelerates incredibly
that's the like it's just brutal
sometimes and you have to look every
single time or else he's gonna get you
oh whoops I wanted oh I've thought about
death coining toy Freddy but in in all
honesty like I can deal with them and it
fits into what Mark did I just it fits
into what I'm like my strategy so why
not leave it don't know what that was
about but I saw the guitar so
oh I know I had the mask now I'm getting
just sloppy now I'm just getting sloppy
[Music]
no this is totally possible like this
isn't even the hardest mode but this is
totally possible because I've gotten to
4:30 what the [ __ ] that was early oh hey
hate you guys
you guys are being real sushi sometimes
it's just like that like right off the
bat it'll be absolute anarchy and other
times it'll actually be nice
every freakin time trying to do a thing
here that's suppose i that usually
happens like that little guy comes in
pack it up spend some time and wind that
[Music]
that's why there's moses the problem
with the problem with chica is that her
sound loop ends like it ends ends and
that's a problem because when you're in
a hurry like i am it can throw you off
and then suddenly you die because you
thought one thing and it ended up for
some reason let's go in you
okay I saw that I got two 15s coming up
god damn it suck a lot you suck a lot
why now really wants me to die to this a
4:00 a.m. I thought it was boy really
[Music]
okay well I can't forget that the
plushie I have the coins I always hate
that's my that's my least favorite wave
of dying is just having coins to like I
have the things I need to win I just
don't do it I just don't do it
mmm all right my throat's still not
doing 100% I'll get there the sickness
will leave me when it feels like it but
not today
oh I hate you
so he so Opie Alaura to Opie oh [ __ ] ah
god damn it I hate that that's unfair
that's unfair that's unfair cuz I'm
screwed either way I'm screwed either
way cuz it's like when you when they
come out right when I was supposed to go
to fun town foxy it's like a year to
screw
oh do not get flappy Oh [ __ ] I
flapped away chica
or foxy whatever that's what happens Wow
for some reason like that body rock star
body just like is perfectly camouflaged
to me like my eyes are blind to that
Bonnie or dot because you know I'm
incredibly mediocre
[Applause]
no no no I hate you
gah go way [ __ ] hate I hate I hate
Valora why does bow Laura why does
Belarus static out the screen as well as
make everything go dark like just how
does that make sense at all oh because
like when that happens I can't see if
say Rockstar chica is there and then
there's literally like literally it's a
50/50 shot of whether or not
the wet floor sign is in the right place
you know oh come on Jesus Christ come on
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh and now I'm super
low on power oh yeah yeah this is this
is about as bad as it could go and I
lost on three coins there
[Music]
[ __ ] you God [ __ ] you so much oh my god
ah nah holy [ __ ] I have no idea why that
happened or how I'm even remotely still
alive but okay we're just gonna go with
a solid okay on that of the guitar
[Music]
and then I they have a boy they it's
always one thing always one thing one
thing or another
oh yeah yeah at least this night isn't
nearly as long as the other ones I just
go away go away oh my god that takes too
long
that's imbalanced see there no time to
act
[Music]
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah okay here we go
also I'm getting really lucky cuz I'm
not using the heater enough to guarantee
that I don't get killed by the the dudes
up and yonder away completely lost my
goddamn mind cuz I have no idea what I'm
doing
no coins really
well that's fun yeah bye-bye
Oh a dove one short really I'm one short
by a death coin that threw me off
incredibly it's like when I as soon as I
get as soon as they get thrown off my
rhythm it all goes to Garbo oh yeah oh
but ends of happens
banana and then the desert and Showtime
please deposit five coins
oh you suck so much Wow you suck so much
oh god I need the guitar hello this is
killing my battery cuz I gotta I gotta
go I gotta get if it's not one thing
it's another if it's not one thing it's
another I say this is what's really hard
about it was like just juggling so many
things the human brain can only think
about so much at once it just becomes
this it's so easy to forget something
like I thought it was hard back when it
was just a few characters but man things
have taken a turn for the worse
know what I wanted why did that happen
see that's that's that's why I didn't
[Music]
every time every time every time it's
always foxy it's uh every time why is
that so hard for me I don't get it like
this has been my Bane the bane of my
existence for the past two days straight
just this [ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ]
[ __ ] here and I can't remember I
don't know why I have so much trouble
remembering because it's like the one
thing my brain can't handle all this
like all this fast stuff this fine but
when it comes down to just looking at
the time my brain is just absolutely
incapable of even the simplest the
simplest of memory
[Music]
didn't mean for that to happen I need so
many more coins than what I have right
now
[Applause]
oh my god I I just passed up on like
five points because I could not make up
my mind that's my power incredibly - am
too am too am too am that's 130 130
don't forget 130 why is it always down
why is it always down and forgetting
it's always the same things always the
same
[Music]
3 a.m. 3 a.m. - 15 - 15 - 15
is awfully quiet
[Music]
mm coming up right now course god why I
haven't done that in so long I haven't
done that and so I haven't swept across
with my flashlight in so long
ah man I haven't done that in so long I
haven't done that in ages man it's
amazing how just like an old mistake
will pop up from way way way way way
gone no coins okay no coins
there's three coins there yeah
I'm doing real bad on power I don't know
why cuz I keep leaving doors open that's
why oh god damn it I didn't get a check
I forgot to death coin my god I cannot
believe that that is just the stupidest
thing I'm probably game over if I had to
guess
[Music]
I wasn't using the heater I don't think
Rockstar Freddie activated a single time
there I was gonna be dead anyway cuz if
foxy I didn't I didn't death
I didn't death foxy I didn't kill foxy I
didn't murder foxy I didn't murder him
dead I didn't kill him I didn't kill him
dead I didn't murder him yeah Orvil of
all people oh I wasn't using the heater
like I should because I was too worried
about my power consumption but alas when
you worry about one thing you lose to
another
to a up 130 130 easy-peasy 130 oh that's
bad that was really bad
just leaving doors wide open like that
is the worst thing that you could do
I need to death going him right now oh
boy
that was me trying to cuz I knew I
hadn't seen foxy in ages oh just like
not not that foxy the other foxy I knew
I hadn't seen him in ages so I was like
I gotta I gotta get ahead of the curve
there but it's alright that's bad that's
even worse let's see if we can bring it
back I did good thing cool man I don't
know what's wrong with me
No
for those saying that it was next to
impossible to get 20 coins before and I
just I have 20 coins right now I want to
say that so as soon as I start talking
it's like start talking I disagree I
disagree a lot of people are going for
high score and I totally get that that's
the way the game is built I don't think
that's the right approach especially if
you want to like tackle the problems
from where they are because yeah there
are there are cheaper ways that you
could go through this even this what I'm
doing right now
there's cheaper ways that you could beat
this because I almost beat yesterday
totally fine and my strategy was
completely different from what I was
doing right now what I'm doing right now
it's it's like it's intentionally the
harder route it's intentionally the
harder up because it's the skills you're
gonna need for later on like that that
is that is absolutely what it's what I'm
doing here it may seem nonsensical to
make it harder for myself but if you're
looking at it because I don't care about
the points I don't I literally don't
care about scores what I'm looking for
is what is the most efficient way what
is the best way
what is the goodest method and then
that's why I'm doing it so there are
other ways to go about it and I could
use the power-ups that's not the point
here power-ups are a crutch the game
technically ideally a game would be
beatable without power-ups like it seems
a little a little iffy about that but I
know I can beat this this way because I
practically did already she I got I got
the 430 a couple times before I started
streaming so I'm like if I start
streaming off I'll know exactly what I'm
doing right there's no way that I'll
ever [ __ ] it up
3 a.m. what the hell
all right all right there okay well I
guess we're uh I guess we uh I guess
we're just that one you know instead of
an enemy killing us that was just the
game decided to not do no more the game
decided the game decided to just let go
away it was like oh he might actually
win this one let's just stop it
prematurely all right then okay all
right here we go
I guess nah it's not pressing Leah you
got a hold escape to return to menu and
that reset like the settings so I don't
know what happened there oh yeah
although thanks for joining me everybody
I am sick so if you see me a little
lower the energy than usual that's why
it's like you could also theorize that
I'm incredibly depressed that you'd be
probably wrong probably I don't know you
do you think whatever you'd like to
think oh yeah so off well missed the
last one but you know what I got enough
I don't need we got 3 a.m. to 15
a bun ends of coins I'm up to 20 I'm up
to 20 coins right now fYI to AF note was
a 3 a.m. I have to turn again I'm
getting backwards wait it's quiet
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
whoa
that was close oh hey buddy it's the
same thing every time every time I wish
I wasn't terrible guys I really do I
wish I wasn't
and yet it's it's exactly
that's exactly what I don't want this is
not fifty twenty this is fifty-five
its power consumption right off the bat
one antler
ooh
almost missed that I don't know why I
thought it was a good idea to take off
my mask then but I did 3 a.m. 3 a.m. -
15 - 15 don't forget it
most time but not yet at night I saw
that guitar man almost missed that Oh
God I'm I'm losing it
[ __ ] I'm really losing it I don't know
why [ __ ] oh man I've just totally lost
it I don't even know why shitty titties
I can't I couldn't for some reason my
brain was just not doing anything I like
I don't know why like I could not I
could not even remotely think of what I
was doing huh man I think that's a sick
brain like my like just my brain is this
late you shouldn't be doing anything let
alone trying this stupid [ __ ] why
don't you shut down for a bit like for a
full 20 seconds there I just brain
farted absolutely
oh yeah I probably would have had that
if I like that would have been that
would have been a fine round I was
pretty good on power but like I said I
could not brain to save my life
- am too am too am too am too am too am
hello you're here a little early oh come
on
this one thing throws me off like that's
that's where I am right now is just like
one thing one thing will throw me off
absolutely one thing will throw me off
and then I completely lose track it's
for some reason really hard for me to
get back on track afterwards I chose
that miss click again I knew that before
you even happened
we almost did the sweep again no coins
for me
Oh Who am I click anon foxy and not that
also that's still really tough to
double-click Scott it's pretty tough oh
[ __ ] and I'm gonna be knocked out is oh
I wasn't thankfully uh oh how
unfortunate I don't have enough coins
yes give me a break you piece of [ __ ]
what was it oh boy
ah this is easy enough that one's not so
bad I just got to turn on the AC
again really you sure you want to do
that Oh foxy I forgot again let me see
what I am almost Showtime
oh wow
four okay that's cool too I almost did a
mega die honestly I have no idea why I'm
still alive after that but you know
beggar chooser I'm not a loser yet oh no
oh no
[Music]
where I am almost swept again Gloria why
no not quite
never mind for it
almost four three three o'clock is four
here we go four am coming right well I
see you I saw you up there and boom six
so I just got to end the game on that
ass so I just got at the the trick is I
got to have enough power to get to that
point that's the actual challenge of
this is the challenge isn't really you
know that you get there let's say you
get there with power because you have to
no no you just have to have it
it's gonna be close
I don't know if I'm gonna have enough
Hey
Oh IIIi e-i-e-i-o your yoyoyoyoyo yeah
with power to spare even though I did
flub up power a lot that is why like
that is why I went through the strategy
that I did for that one and I got like
they didn't go easy on me on that one
either that's why I wanted this strategy
is so that people could use this to go
farther now I don't know if it's
adaptable to 20 mode I haven't even
tried it I'm gonna do a few tries here
but like that that is the crux of it
that is it I was able to get on on good
tries I was able to get 20 coins in the
beginning I think you'd get more just
judging on how many times you'd actually
get coins from people hitting your doors
but that is 55 that is ridiculously hard
just 55 mode is super duper duper duper
D hard like legitimately
hard hard hard hard hard but with enough
practice it does become the the enough
of the skills does become second nature
and you can do that you can play through
this with like you can do it with luck
you could you could find ways to exploit
things like uses the mechanics in
certain ways to get luck through there
and chance your way through that's not
what I wanted I wanted a repeatable
formula where the only one messing up
was me cuz if I left it up to the game
to mess me up I'd get pissed off but
this was actually fun I've had a great
time trying to get this whereas if you
know me from other games like getting
over it or even the other five nights at
Freddy's games when the only way through
is RNG I get super pissed off because
then it's not my fault this was just all
these mistakes were just my fault
so this is but this is just 55 now I
don't know there's probably
gonna need to be a lot of adaptations
420 mode and I don't know for sure if
anything that I got going on is good
enough because with this I know there's
another level with the heater that you
got to use the heater more and more more
more or else you're just gonna get
screwed over by these guys but let's
give this a few tries it's not gonna
look pretty because well number one is
just not but let's you know let's see
what happens oh yeah hey oh hey oh oh
hey okay yeah I had my mask on wait I
had my mask on I had my mask on I was
not fair
ah
oh [ __ ] well that's less than ideal oh
you are moved okay I got it
there's a lot more on screen at the same
time so it's hard for me to discern the
information I need right away but I
think it's largely I say that with as
much confidence as I can muster it's
largely the same I clicked on you
there's no way that I do ten seconds is
really all you give me I guess you got
to use the global music box but yeah I
doubt that's you know there's definitely
gonna need some quirks already right off
the bat because if he if that's if you
only give me ten seconds to get there
that means the global music box has to
be on from the get-go like you Freddie
I didn't put my mask down
so you only take eights so there needs
to be so you can't spend nearly as much
time in the menu that's for sure those
games are yeah this is why I didn't I
didn't from the get-go I had strong
doubts on whether or not whether or not
you know it would even be possible to
beat this mode as well
whoops I pressed the wrong button there
[ __ ] well new record 22 seconds
yeah when everyone hits at once I think
when everyone hits it once is when you
need the global music box because you
just can't make it over in there in time
that wasn't even that bad let me keep
let me just do a few more tries I don't
think I don't think I'm gonna get to
this in time
see the problem with this is if if
everyone is being just a giant [ __ ]
about world I forgot about old man
consequences oops if everyone's being a
giant [ __ ] at the same time then I
highly doubt unless there's some super
mechanical precision for exactly what
you'd need exactly when you need it and
even then like I don't even know
I could not click it I miss you at Oh
bunny yeah I know I saw shadow Bonnie
shadow body doesn't mean anything for
this that I'm doing right here because
if you remember what the doors are
you're not gonna run into any problems
anyway so it's not really that big a
deal oh come on uh I swear I'm hitting
that when I'm hitting that can I please
all right I guess the global music box
it is oh Jesus
oh really
well that was like I went surprisingly
long for me messing up so badly yeah
yeah the problem with all these things
the problem with pretty much any of
these modes is is it's an overwhelming
amount of information at first but I'm
wondering if there's a way come on just
oh it's it's off that's all right I
can't see [ __ ]
hmm there's a new record 23 not 26 is my
record try 50 10 first I want to give
this a few more tries because there's
this there's some things that are
impossible and I want to find out what
it is
I gotta I gotta remember to click well
[Music]
you get like half a second on that but
if you're doing it automatically anyway
I just didn't expect my monitor to
people down so in the in the first phase
I don't have enough time to do anything
I can't
I think coin hunting is just out I think
coin hunting is pretty much out but with
so many people hitting the walls you're
gonna have you're gonna have so many
coins anyway so I don't think it matters
the danger is just gonna be finding when
and where you can go into the monitor
for why am I not I'm not pulling up my
mask automatically anymore I've
completely lost it
I've lost all my skill whatever skill I
had which was none this is a doozy oh
[ __ ] forgot to put
I'm losing it already
I'm completely forgetting my my my
entire existence ah there we go okay ah
there Oh what am i doing oh god my brain
my brain is my brain but from what I was
seeing there it's nearly impossible but
I don't know I don't know because I'm
kind of starting to learn it you see
what you see what I mean like again I'm
not making it very far obviously I'm not
but I'm kind of seeing like the rules
for this but even so like I don't know
[Music]
boopie oh [ __ ] well I was wrong oh boy
[ __ ] you woof double okay double double
toilet wow you were in there before her
oh yes boy Hey
well no I'm not trying to beat it I'm
not like there there's no way that I'm
gonna be to because already I can tell
even if there was a way to learn the
pattern even if those away oh come on I
flicked it alright well I guess I'll
just sit here then Wow
you know this is fun I'll just even if
there was a way to memorize his pattern
get it go for it like get-get the
distance on it like I don't it wouldn't
be worth the effort in my mind see it's
too easy to flub up your things see you
can respond you can respond to the
threats you can respond to the threats
like that's totally possible it's not
it's insane it's it's insane like
physically it'd take a long time of
figuring [ __ ] out but yet like
eventually eventually could do it if you
just got the instincts because it didn't
take me too long to get to oh I'm
apparently my screens down I didn't even
know that I couldn't see anything
because it didn't take me long to get
the instincts to be able to be quick
like in 55 this is just a whole nother
level of quick and just like this is
just everything would have to be
completely subconscious you you just
analyze information
[Music]
really oh yeah this would be the hardest
part just like balancing between I
totally forgot that you were there yeah
I think the problem is raising up and
raising down the the monitor is a
trigger event for too many characters at
once so you end up with just this
overwhelming surge of people in this
there's probably next to nowhere next in
no way to be able to get it enough that
you could survive it
[Music]
I'm gonna give it just a couple more
tries because this is this is obviously
not going to happen but on a city oh
well this this makes it impossible I
think one of the other things you have
to do is you have to always move I was
kind of doing it in the other one you
often to always move your mouse to the
very end of the road that sounds bad all
right oh I thought I had my bench closed
apparently not
oh yeah no I beat 55 mode I'm just
seeing if if in any way this strategy
can translate and it sort of can the
heater the heater I forgot to activate
the heater yeah on top of everything
else that's happening in the middle of
it you have to cycle in using the here
which is just crazy so you have to do
basically is there even gonna be enough
power see that's that's that's the first
piece of information that I saw that
maybe like that's pointing to the idea
that it's impossible because I was
running low on power before here like
with all these characters and was trying
to remember everything doing this
methodology I don't think this is gonna
work but that's fine because I am good
for now I am sick I am satisfied I beat
55 mode it's possible that fifty ten
mode could be also something that's
doable but like I don't like luck I
don't want to deal with luck I'm good
for now I've got other things that I
want to do I've got other games that I
want to play so I'm going to call this
as the end of ultimate custom night for
me if anyone wants to take any
information that I provided and try to
put it forward into any other strategy I
think it would be technically possible
to adapt some things that I was doing in
a larger scale but with 50 20 mode there
needs to be some really really
fine-tuned rules for it like there's if
you turn on the heater every time you
bring the monitor up like
turn the air-conditioning every time you
bring it down flashlight to the left
like quickly look cuz I was able to look
and see if a nightmare BB was up and
Adam but then like it does need some
work and it's more work than I'd ever
care for so good luck to everybody else
who wants to try that I'm going to move
on to more better things to do and then
thank you everybody so much for 21
million subscribers I really appreciate
that you have really joined a mediocre
team with a mediocre figurehead if you
want to see some really really average
and subpar videos in your sub feed and
you haven't subscribed yet hey why not
consider ruining your day and hitting
that sub button you want to be notified
whenever something that you don't want
to watch is there hit that Bell button
yeah you want to be coerced into hitting
a like button hey smash that thumb
you'll be and thank you everybody so
much for watching I have got a pet
that's calling my name and I am going to
go there so thanks again everybody you
guys have a wonderful night take care
love you all have a good one
thanks for watching as always I'll see
you in the next video bye bye